des consommateurs sous l'emprise de
l'addiction des habitants excédés le
fléau du crack est toujours bien présent
en france et notamment dans la capitale
ici on a par exemple un exemple typique
de cracker qui fument en fait en plein
milieu de la rue parce que on a beau
dire qu'en fait c'est interdit et c'est
vrai que il se hisse ils peuvent faire
ce qu'ils veulent dans certains
quartiers comme ici dans le 19e
arrondissement est la présence des
consommateurs fait grimper le sentiment
d'insécurité nombreux sont les riverains
à se sentir désarmé on essaye d'appeler
la police a vient pas on essaye de le
contacter la mairie tout ça ils font
rien on sait plus comment comment
interagir avec donc on appelle les
journalistes on essaye de faire des
vidéos de faire du bruit quoi pour que
nous laisse pas comme ça parce que parce
qu'on ne peut plus tout simplement il
faut arriver à soigner ces gens là il
faut qu'on puisse vivre dans un
atmosphère sereine riverains c'est très
difficile très très dur on sait plus
comment et qu'est ce qu'on doit faire il
ya quelques jours rien une quinzaine
d'avions et un viol husson face à bah
vous voyez une situation qui pousse
certaines personnes au déménagement
ancienne résidente du quartier juliette
a pris la décision de partir moi
j'habitais dans l'immeuble oui
d'aubervilliers pendant 25 ans c'était
infernal les toxicos on ouvrait la porte
pour descendre pour aller prendre
l'ascenseur pour aller travailler le
matin en les poussières du côté des
usagers tomber dans l'addiction peut
aller très vite pour ce consommateur que
nous appellerons didier paris représente
une tentation trop forte qu'il faut fuir
à tout prix pour se sortir de cette
spirale infernale c'est qu'il veuille
partir pouvoir à bout de cent kilomètres
de pavés
cccc mieux à faire les régates d'être
venu ici vous ment pas c'est mon pire
cauchemar c'est paris savais pas que ça
allait se passer comme ça à en croire
les chiffres de l'association gaïa il
existerait près de 5000 fumeurs de crack
rien que dans le nord-est de la capitale